this video is brought to you by nordvpn
so it's that time that time of again
when people are going to be writing new
goals starting new training programs
Etc but wouldn't it be cool if instead
of following a cookie cutter workout you
instead came up with your whole own
training style I believe that by drawing
from a massive pool of different
training Styles and taking what works
for you you can create something
completely unique and perfectly
customized to you and your goals and as
an added bonus it's going to be
something that you actively enjoy doing
obviously this is something that not a
lot of people are going to know how to
do if they're starting out in training
and so that's the purpose of this video
here we're going to learn how to create
your own training style something that
you're really going to stick with so you
can properly kick ass in 2023
so the first thing you're going to want
to do is sit down and write out your
goals what is it you hope to achieve
from your training program there's lots
of different things you could put here
it could be that you want to look better
so Aesthetics maybe you want to be
stronger maybe you want to be more
athletic whether that means more
explosive or whether you want to improve
your endurance you might just want to
move better you might want to prevent
some of the downsides of Aging or you
might have any other number of goals
what I'd say is don't just put down one
goal put down as many as you want
because there's no reason you have to
choose just one outcome for your
training I think this is a common
misconception a lot of people think for
example that you can't train for max
strength and Aesthetics for instance
however power Builders would beg to
differ so write down as much as you want
and perhaps try and grade them in terms
of what's more important to you do you
really want to be massively strong and
you kind of want a bit of endurance as
well what are these things about equal
footing
[Music]
my car got recalled so I've had to come
here to kidlington to drop it off trying
to find some spots to do some filming
and I found a canal so that's cool
from there what you're going to do is
look for a kind of Base training style
so one that matches most of your goals
so for example if you're more interested
in building strength then you might
start with a power lifting program if
you're more interested in building
strength to weight ratio then you might
start with a calisthenics program if
you're more interested in movement and
Mobility then you might start with a
movement training program and then this
is going to serve as a kind of Baseline
and you're going to build off of this
from there swapping out the things that
you do and don't want to create
something more personalized to you
when you're browsing the web researching
different training modalities it's
important to stay protected and that's
why ignored VPN can be such a powerful
tool for anyone who does a lot of
research online so nordvpn is today's
sponsor it's a VPN you've heard me talk
about them before a VPN is a virtual
private Network and what this means is
that you can relay your traffic via a
server located elsewhere thus
obfuscating your location and your
information hiding it from your ispn as
well as anybody who might be trying to
watch what you're doing
now this is useful for multiple reasons
for one it allows you to browse content
that might otherwise be restricted in
your region but more importantly this is
also really good for security so a great
example of how this might protect you is
in the case of a man in the middle
attack in a man in the middle attack you
might be connected to what you think is
the coffee Shop's Wi-Fi when in fact
you've accidentally connected to a fake
Wi-Fi set up by the hacker sitting in
the corner of the room fortunately if
you use a VPN then all your traffic is
going to go straight to that server and
they're not going to be able to see
anything else other than that they won't
see your passwords they'll see what
sites you browse and you'll remain
completely safe
nordvpn is actually the fastest VPN
according to the latest speed test too
so when you're ready to get started go
to nordvpn.com to learn more and if you
use the link in the description down
below you'll be entitled to four months
free as well as 30 day money back
guarantee so check it out and thanks
once again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video
doing a surprise twist my car is
actually ready really early so I was
able to go and collect it I've changed
into my gym gear and I've come to be
really nearby kirtlington which is a
beautiful little place actually and I've
trained here before but I understand
there's actually a park here as well
which I've not seen before so I'm gonna
go and check that out and we'll carry on
here shall we
so now you have your foundational
training program and what you're going
to do from here is going to look at it
and think which of my goals does this
accomplish and which ones is it not so
useful for so for example let's say that
you're interested primarily in building
Aesthetics and muscle so you chose a
bodybuilding training program perhaps a
conventional bro split but you also want
to be able to do the planche that's one
of your other goals well it's gonna be
tricky to be a bodybuilder who can plan
because you're going to be heavier but
it would be really cool so why not shoot
for the stars you're going to find that
that bodybuilding split doesn't have
much for straight arm strength training
because that doesn't really benefit
bodybuilders so if you want to train for
plants as well you simply find some
straight arm exercises things like
pseudo planche push-ups or tuck planche
holes something like that and then you
put them into the program what you're
not going to do though is simply add
them onto the program because you've got
to think about things like fatigue
you've got to think about how many hours
there are in the day so in this case you
might look at your bodybuilding program
and you're gonna have to make some
promises and you might think what can I
afford to lose and I'd say that if
you're doing straight arm training you
maybe don't need quite as much for your
biceps you can probably drop a few of
the sets of bicep curls maybe you don't
need to do as many chin ups for example
because straight arm training will also
provide some bicep size and this is why
gymnasts have famously such massive
biceps or if one of your goals is to
learn a handstand then maybe you're
going to throw in some handstand
training or some Pike push-ups and
replace your military presses or some of
your dumbbell presses not all of them
but some of them do this successfully
though you need to do your research
obviously and you need to learn what
different exercises are for and what
they do look at which muscle groups they
Target and then try and find equivalence
in different training modalities so if
you are tired of doing your seated rows
for example then perhaps you're going to
do some arched back pull-ups to Target
those same back muscles I will say as
well make sure you're not limiting
yourself in terms of the different pools
of exercises you draw from there are so
many different modalities out out there
for example I've been doing standing
like a tree which is actually from
Qigong I do marbu that's horse stance
that comes from Kung Fu you can pick
exercises from dance from parkour from
gymnastics strength training from any
kind of Athletics there's so many
options out there so don't limit
yourself you will as well of course have
to think about programming and how to
progress these exercises over time so
for example if you're doing the planche
holds you're going to want to increase
the hold time over time maybe move
through more difficult progressions
that's different than just adding weight
to say a bench press so if you don't
know how to do this then you need to
watch some YouTube videos do some
research or alternatively look at other
programs that do incorporate those moves
and they kind of smush the two programs
together to create something new
this is why I also really appreciate
bang for your buck exercises those
exercises that provide multiple benefits
all at once so if you take something
like a rope climb this isn't just great
for your lats it's also great for your
biceps also great for your core
especially if you do it with an l-sit
position also great for your grip
something important to understand here
is that you're always going to be making
some compromises here particularly with
bang for your buck exercises of course
by doing an exercise that combines
multiple movement patterns into one
you're not going to be reaching fatigue
in as many of those patterns this is
where you decide if you want to be a
broader athlete an all-rounder or
whether you want to hone in on something
more specific and you're going to find
every time that you gravitate towards a
program as you find that perhaps you're
doing a little bit too much or perhaps
you've got a little bit of space to do
something more maybe you enjoy one thing
more than the other and you're going to
add and take away things from there so
it doesn't have to be perfect right away
when it comes to combining something
like a form of cardio with power lifting
it pays to think about which types of
cardio complement other types of
training so for example walking can be
great for powerlifting or bodybuilding
because it helps to circulate blood
without creating a lot of cortisol a lot
of myostatin similarly resistance cardio
is also very good that means any form of
cardio where you're pushing at some form
of resistance or pulling some form of
resistance things like battle ropes
heavy bag training and high intensity
interval training is also really good
use as a finisher and that's another
great way to combine cardio with
something like power lifting or
bodybuilding is to use at the end of
your workouts as a finisher if you plan
on combining things like cardio and
heavy lifts then there's a simple
methodology to follow you just want to
place the more technical lifts and
movements things like branch and hand
balancing along with any highly
neurologically taxing movements very
heavy movements compound movements like
bench press Squat and deadlift they're
going to go at the start of the workout
when you're fresh obviously after your
warm-up or your warm-up set then as you
move through the workout consider it
like a spectrum moving on to supported
single joint movements and closed chain
movements things like high repetition
push-ups and pull-ups things like
machines and then right at the end of
course you can switch all the way back
to cardio and resistance cardio
well I'm losing light now guys so I'll
end on this final note and that's to
think about what kind of training what
exercises and modalities you enjoy it's
not just about your goals you want your
workouts to be intrinsically motivating
as well so that you enjoy doing them
that's how you want to feel about your
own training style you want it to be
uniquely you you want it to reflect your
personality your body the way you move
and by choosing things you gravitate
towards not shying away from your
weaknesses mind just training in ways
that you enjoy you're going to achieve
that so you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave it a like and share it around that
really genuinely does help me massively
if you enjoy this kind of training that
combines multiple modalities into a
single hybrid style you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 that comes with
over two hours of instructional video
and I recommend you use that by looking
at the different training Styles and
mixing and matching them into your own
workouts not just following it blindly
there will be things you like things you
can easily do and things you don't like
so much or don't have the facilities for
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you in
the new year bye for now and Merry
Christmas to those of you who celebrate
it happy holidays to everybody else have
an amazing one